The OTSC New Year's Eve Solidarity General
happens every year.
Obviously this year
the call for solidarity
Palestine rings louder than ever
and we're watching a genocide involved.
25,000 people have been murdered inside Gaza.
2.3 million people have been displaced
and it really horrific scenes uh.
Of films being destroyed,
of basic infrastructure falling apart. Uh.
So we really need to.
In 2024 this solidarity movement escalates.
That means uh.
The explosion of designer's
the bastard from Ireland.
It means uh.
Following South Africa's lead by supporting
international prosecution of designer state.
It means uh.
Escalating the BBS campaign engine. All trade,
economic uh.
And political
cultural ties to the state of Israel. Uh.
Appreciative.
You have to realize that these are American made bombs
that are falling on Gazette.
It's an American supported and enabled genocide.
Without US support
at the international political level
and at the military level
this would not be able to continue.
So when it comes to Patrick's day,
we shouldn't see any Irish politicians
handling over Boulder Shamrock in the White House.
We need to come down strong
and America, we need to.
It's Irish America
to put pressure on American politicians
in an election year.
And we need to really escalate this movement
to underground
in Dublin so.
And across the country.
So January 13th
I believe to be an international day of action.
The big protest here in Dublin
and order actions besides that.
So get out, get out strong,
spread the word
and let's end this Genocide.
Let's get a ceasefire.
Let's stand and solidarity
the Palestinian people free